Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I'm back, guys, for the second stream of the day.
So, for those who don't know, I've never grew up playing Halo before.
So, this would be, like, my first time experiencing it.
And I've never played a campaign before.
I did play multiplayer with you guys a long time ago in a member stream.
But I've never grew up with Halo.
I don't really know much about the lore of Halo.
I just know that the main character's name is Master Chief.
And he's supposed to be mute.
He doesn't talk at all.
So, like, when they released a new, like, what was it?
The TV show.
The live-action Halo TV show.
And then, like, Mr. Halo started talking and taking out of his helmet and started talking.
Oh, he does talk?
Oh, he talks sometimes.
See, this is what I mean.
I don't know much about Halo.
I don't know much about John Halo.
So, he doesn't talk a lot.
Okay.
Apparently, in the live-action, he talks a lot.
And he also, like, takes off his helmet.
And then, all the Halo guys were like, how dare he?
The helmet stays on.
How fucking dare he take it off?
That's not my John Halo.
And also, yeah.
And then he started banging some chick.
That's all I know about the live-action.
Um, next thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So excited to see you play Halo.
I hope you enjoy it.
Netbearers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bite Size.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
I'm so happy you finally had the chance to play Halo.
This series was a big part of my childhood.
So I hope you have a great time and enjoy the game!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Jakarta!
Thank you for the Magenta Supa!
Thank you!
Finally, Doki and OG Halo!
Been waiting for this even before that infinite stream!
The Dragoons!
Notes before starting!
Titles in MCC have individual downloads and settings!
Classic and remastered!
Oh yeah!
Don't worry!
I make sure to download Combat Evolved slash Halo 1 before I start a stream.
So don't worry, I got that.
done already.
But thank you for the Magenta Supa!
Thank you!
But yes, I never owned an Xbox growing up.
Because like I said, my dad is a Sony boy.
So he hated any other console but the PlayStation.
So I never got a chance to experience Halo growing up.
I never played the campaigns before.
So I'm going in blind and everything.
I don't know really any of the lore.
of Halo.
I just know that we're killing aliens?
And I'm the green guy.
The only time my dad ever got an Xbox was the Xbox 360.
And he only got it for Gears of War.
That was the only reason why he bought the Xbox!
And he still didn't play Halo!
No!
He didn't play Halo!
He did!
The one Halo game he's ever played was the RTS Halo game on the Xbox 360.
That was the only Halo he played and bought.
Like he didn't buy any other Halo game!
He bought Halo Wars!
And that's it!
That was my only introduction to Halo!
Was the Halo RTS game!
Johnny Lacone!
Thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
I can't believe my OSHA will finally play a game I've loved dearly!
I really hope you enjoy it!
Seeing as Samara is my birthday!
The timing couldn't have been even better!
Incidentally, might I get a happy birthday from you?
Of course, Johnny!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Johnny!
Yeah!
Happy birthday Johnny!
And thank you again for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
That's crazy.
Halo has been around for so fucking long.
Uh, come to think of it.
When... Okay, Halo... Combat Evolve.
When was Combat Evolve?
Because this was the 20th anniversary, right?
2001.
Oh my god.
It's been out for like 24 years now.
That's crazy.
It's crazy that Halo has like, uh, been around for that long.
Um, yeah, it's John Halo time.
Yeah.
Like, bro, he's about to graduate university.
My knees hurt.
Uh, Cecil, welcome to Samantha Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But yeah, I'm super excited to experience Halo for the first time.
And, um, see what this is all about.
You know?
How it basically has such a very...
Um, um, very rapid... Is rapid the right word?
Uh, very supportive, I guess to say.
Very supportive.
Until they made Halo 4.
Uh, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Very...
Very supportive, iconic, dedicated, loyal fanbase that they have.
Um, so, uh, it's, uh, exciting to experience it for the first time.
You know, like, some VTubers, they have their Devil May Cry series, like, uh, uh, uh, playing Devil May Cry for the first time.
Other VTubers, maybe they're playing Metal Gear Solid for the first time.
I am gonna start my Halo arc.
I am gonna...
As the, uh, as the, as the, as the Gamer Bro V...
As the honorary Gamer Bro VTuber, I shall finally start my Gamer Bro arc by starting my Halo arc.
Uh, wait, no, I am in my...
I've always been my Gamer Bro arc.
Well, finally, finally, I will be a true Gamer Bro, guys.
This is my initiation series into becoming a true Gamer Bro.
Ow, bro, playing Halo...
Combat EVVOLVED!
Alright, did I do my...
Oh, my God, I didn't even...
Oh, I did the Master Chief collection area.
Alphaean, thank you for the five, give the ships, thank you, thank you.
Onee, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
What I'm missing right now is my mountain dew.
If you ever enjoy, uh, if you enjoy your Halo arc, check out the cursed Halo mod sometimes.
Fun mod for Halo 1, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You're right.
It's like, that's like initiation number two.
You know, like when you get your driver's license, you have the learner's permit and then like experience permit.
I'm getting my learner's permit right now.
I need my Mountain Dew and Doritos if I really want to play Halo.
Alright, this is that.
Start playing missions from the beginning.
Quick start.
Okay, we're doing normal.
Because I don't... Okay, is there a first attack?
Survival is not... Okay, do we do normal or heroic, guys?
I don't... Heroic?
Do you think I'm... Do you think I'm ready?
Guys, do you think I'm ready?
Guys, am I... Am I ready?
You don't!
Okay, I'll try my... I'll try my best.
I've never played Halo before, so I'm scared.
She's so ready.
Guys, you think I'm ready for this?
Oh my god, it's my first time!
Alright.
I think this is the... Is this the original graphics?
I don't know if I put it on the original or the remastered.
I can't press tab yet.
I'm in the intro.
Oh, this is the remastered?
Okay, I need... I think I have to be, like, be after the cutscene.
I have to...
After the cutscene, I can change it, I'm pretty sure.
I can't change it now, because I'm in a cutscene.
Wait, can I swap?
When I'm...
In the game.
Okay, wait, I'll boost up the audio, too.
Uh...
I'm gonna tap back in.
Holy shit, it's so quiet!
No, I can't... I'm pressing tab.
It won't let me when I'm in cutscene.
Holy shit, it's so quiet.
I am pressing tab, guys.
I'm literally pressing tab.
On the far side of the planet.
Our fighters are mopping up the last of their recon picket now.
Nothing serious.
But I've isolated approach signatures for multiple CCS-class battle groups.
Make it three...
Oh my... I'm... Okay, I'll... I'll up it up, boy.
Holy shit, what is the sound balancing?
I swear to God, it's gonna be out of the cutscene, and it's gonna be so fucking loud.
I'm at, like...
It's based... Everything is quiet.
Let's give our old friends a walk.
Alright, guys.
I've already begun.
Okay.
Maybe, like, out of the cutscene, it'll be better.
There's Cortana.
Oh, I know what Cortana is.
Everybody wants to bang her.
I know her.
Yeah, I'll put Snipe Tiles on, too.
Alright, I'll... I'll boost the audio up even more, for everybody.
I'm just worried that it's gonna be so fucking loud when we get to the gameplay.
It's actually at, like, 0.8 now.
Negative 0.8.
And 0 is, like, the maximum.
Man, here's where we show those split-chain squid-head sons of bitches that they could not have picked a worse enemy than the human race.
We are going to blow the hell out of those dumb bugs until we don't have anything left to shoot them with.
And then we are going to strangle them with their own living guts.
Am I right, Marie?
Oh, you know this was made in the 2000s.
There's always the...
The one very enthusiastic sergeant.
We are re-engaging the enemy.
External and internal...
The motivational speaker.
Sir, yes, sir!
All you greenhorns who wanted to see Covenant up close.
This is gonna be your lucky day.
Hoorah!
I love American military propaganda.
Sir, yes, sir!
That's me!
Is that the Master Chief?
That's Master Chief, right?
Green man!
It's John Halo!
The John Halo!
Okay, let's fix this.
Alright.
Oh, there we go.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
That is so different!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
It's so colorful!
And then...
And then, like, I can count the polygons!
I...
Damn, hey!
Alright.
Oh my god!
Wait!
That's not the same guy!
I can't actually count the polygons!
Okay, let's do the audio.
Alright.
We'll boost it.
Why the...
We boost the game volume up here.
Uh...
I'll put it at 86.
And then...
Game music up by...
Uh...
Okay.
Let's see.
Why would I need voice chat?
Who the fuck's gonna be talking to me?
Yeah!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Save settings.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me make sure.
Alright, so OG Graphics 1.
So we're gonna play on the OG Graphics.
Okay, I'm gonna turn this down.
Alright.
Oh yeah, I forgot subtitles.
Where is the subtitles option?
Settings.
Uh...
Video.
Where is the subtitles?
What the fuck is it?
Do they have subtitles, guys?
Show, invite, multiplayer...
Is that sensibility?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Subtitle settings.
Extra.
Okay, let's do...
Original.
Alright.
That should be good.
And then...
Uh...
That should be good.
We should be good then.
Uh...
We'll put up the music a little bit higher too.
Okay.
Because I know, like, this game has a really good soundtrack too.
Alright.
No weapon.
Alright, hello.
This way.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
That was so loud!
I'm so sorry!
I...
He's so dead.
Oh my god!
Oh, he's dead!
He's dead!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the Yaku Super!
Thank you!
Thank you Halo for...
No!
I had mine really loud!
I...
Because like, my GoXLR separates...
Separates...
Between...
So like, because you guys couldn't hear, I also couldn't hear, so I've turned it up higher too.
Like higher than...
And then...
Oh, he's dead!
What does he look like when...
Oh, he's definitely dead.
Oh my god!
It's so bright!
As per tradition...
For Halo tradition...
I... I got the spirit.
Oh, why did I keep going forward?
Bruh.
Alright.
Isn't that this way?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I couldn't see it.
Hello.
Oh my god, it's so trippy.
I like seeing, like...
I like seeing, like, the difference between, like, the graphics.
Oh, the... Oh my god!
I can actually see what they look like.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Why you close that door?
Okay, I'm going this way.
Hello.
Oh, where's the bridge?
I'm trying to get there as fast as I can!
Do what?
Oh, here.
Here.
Okay, he let me go through this time.
Hello.
What do you look like when you're extra dead?
Oh my god.
Old, young.
Wait, I can see everything.
Okay, you're still young.
I mean, he is not dead.
He got a really good plastic surgeon.
Captain Keyes is waiting for us, sir.
Oh wait, I wanted to see you talk.
I want to know if you sound different, too.
Hello.
Captain Keyes is just swapping between timelines.
He's just swapping between timelines.
Well, Cortana did her best, but we never really had a chance.
A dozen Covenant Superior battleships against a single Halcyon class cruiser.
With those odds, I'm content with three, make them four kills.
Sleep well?
No thanks to your driving.
Yes.
So you did miss me.
Report!
It must have been one of their boarding parties.
Oh no!
I guess an anti-matter charge.
Ma 'am!
Cortana, what do we do?
Captain, the cannon was my last offensive option.
Ah, right then.
I'm initiating cold protocol article two.
We're abandoning the autumn.
It's the Microsoft girl.
Oh yeah!
While you do what?
Go down with the ship?
In a manner of speaking.
The object we found, I'm going to try and land the autumn on it.
With all due respect, sir, this war has enough dead heroes.
I appreciate your concern, Cortana, but it's not up to me.
Oh, why would you ever insult Cortana?
Look at her!
Look at the perfect angle, too.
Lock in a selection of emergency landing zones.
Upload them to my neural lace.
And then sort yourself for a heart transfer.
Aye, aye, sir.
Which is where you come in, chief.
Get Cortana off this ship.
Keep her safe from the enemy.
If they capture her, they'll learn everything.
Force deployment, weapons research.
Just delete her.
Control-Alt-Delete.
The autumn will continue evasive maneuvers until you initiate a landing sequence.
Not that you'll listen, but I'd suggest letting my subroutines handle the final approach.
No, I can't.
Not in this.
I can't swap.
Thank you.
Uh.
Are you ready?
I can't swap graphics and cutscenes.
No.
It won't let me.
It just says press space to skip.
Beamer.
Beamer up.
Good luck, master chief.
That's me.
I don't need luck.
Your architecture isn't much different from the autos.
I just need my mounted, dude.
Don't keep it loaded, son.
You'll have to find ammo as you go.
What the fuck?
We're in a military ship.
Why do you not have it loaded?
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you know in a critically acclaimed and very accurate to the Halo Lord Halo TV show?
They made...
They showed John Halo's ass.
That happens in the game later on, too.
Sorry for the spoilers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't have melee.
Wait, do I?
No, I don't.
I was trying to see if I could have melee or not.
That's right.
I don't need cover.
I do?
Do I have melee?
Wait, I gotta figure out how to melee.
Give me a sec.
Control of this.
Where the fuck is melee?
Where am I?
Oh, computer bindings.
Okay.
Crouch.
Space.
Fire.
Zoom.
Q!
Okay, I'm putting that...
I'll put that here.
And then I'll put that on my other mouse.
And that should be good.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I have a flashlight?
What's my flashlight?
Oh, there it is.
Four!
That should be F.
Okay.
There we go.
There you go.
Now it's better.
Okay.
There we go.
I lost him.
I know you're there!
There you go.
Just run and gun.
That's right.
I'm strafing!
Deion can't handle this!
Oh, shit!
Wait, he can beat me up, too?
Okay, maybe I...
Oh!
Okay, I know how I'm playing now.
I know how I'm playing.
I'm not gonna fuck around.
Okay, maybe I'll use a little cover.
I was not paying attention to my healers, by the way.
I...
I didn't think it was a super chat.
Was it noticeable?
I wasn't paying attention to my health.
I can't believe it!
He can fucking fight back!
You're a bot!
What?
Jesus Christ.
I can't just leave, you signed up for the army!
Okay, I need... Wait, how do I... Oh my god!
What?!
Where was the grenade?!
Where the fuck?!
Oh my god, I'm blind!
I'm...
That sticks to me?!
Oh my god, I didn't know that sticks to me.
Oh, wait, what the fuck is this gun?
Okay, now I know.
Okay, guys, I'm learning.
Jesus Christ, I don't know if I like this gun.
Yeah, I'm not a fan of this one.
Stop!
That's illegal!
Okay, I'm not... I'm not a fan of this gun.
I need something else.
Oh no.
Don't suck me!
Don't stick me!
I'm trying to find another gun!
Guys, did any of our own people die?
So I can steal their gun?
Yeah, the common elites are pretty elite.
They can... They can dodge?!
Okay, where... Where'd I put... Okay, there you go.
There's my other gun.
Alright.
Oh, I'm not used to using, uh... Number keys to swap weapons.
Stupid.
Okay, now I know it's a shitty gun.
Oh, man.
Whoa!
Jesus, why is this so bright in the remastered?
It's like being like it's too... It's too dark and depressing.
Gotta make it brighter.
Is pistol better?
Okay, I'll try the pistol.
It's so fucking bright.
Jesus, they're dodging!
He's dodging!
Weaving and weaving!
Get up!
Get up so I can kill you again!
Okay, he's dead, guys.
He's dead.
Stop.
What the hell?
Did something just hit us?
Move in!
Back to the airlock!
Alright.
I'm going this way.
Hello, guys.
Oh!
Goodbye, guys!
Goodbye!
You guys got this, right?
You clearly have a lot of HP, I believe.
Oh my god, no.
Not my ammo.
If you guys die, I can steal your gun.
I would like that.
It's okay if you die.
That's right.
Go in there.
Go in there, guys.
I would like to take your ammo.
What's in here?
Oh, nothing.
Whoa!
What did I do?
They're using our lifeboat airlocks to attach their boarding craft.
I could kill the Marines?
Guys, if I kill the Marines, I can steal their ammo.
Whoa!
That's right.
Did he see you?
Come on the way!
That's fucking right.
I saw you.
Come on the head, Cheek.
We'll secure it in there.
True.
You don't need it, anyway.
No.
I don't want that gun.
Do it, coward.
You need more ammo.
I'll do it later, guys.
That's right.
Surprise attack.
Bitch.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He didn't see me.
That's right.
Surprise.
Surprise flank.
Nice.
I don't have enough for...
Hello, guys.
I did it.
Okay, wait.
I have ammo.
Okay, you're lucky.
I... I was double-checking if I needed...
I was double-checking if I needed more ammo.
If I needed them to be dead.
Protect the little guys.
P.S.
They're pretty confident in fights.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mmm.
But I'm more confident, though.
But they're kill-stealing me.
Do I really want to let them live if they're kill-stealing?
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
I get... Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm just gonna throw my nade out.
There we go.
Go get near it.
Don't get near it!
Nice.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay, I didn't expect... Oh, my God!
Okay, that's fine.
I have this.
I have that.
I have so many of this.
Oh, nice sticky.
Nice sticky.
That's why I did that.
Can I break that shield?
No, I can't.
I was curious if I could.
A secret will happen if you kill five of them.
I...
Mmm.
It sounds so believable.
Is there anything here?
I'm gonna throw some nades real quick.
Oh, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead.
My shields.
Wait there!
What the fuck are you doing here?!
Okay.
I actually have to take cover.
That's right.
Suppressing fire!
What?
Is... Did he just leave?
Wait, does it actually... Okay, I'm coming back.
Where are they?
Alright.
They said it would be a silly secret.
Did I kill five of them?
I can't tell.
It's been so long.
Hey, where did they all go?
Where did all you guys go?
Where did they all go?
They just all disappeared.
Oh, they are all dead!
Oops.
Clearly it wasn't my fault.
Wait, then what happened to my secret?
I was promised a fun secret.
Very good.
Wait, how do you guys know how many I killed?
How do you guys know that?
Wait, are you keeping track?
What the fuck?!
Oh!
Okay, I thought that he was already dead.
That's why I went up to him.
I don't know why I keep thinking he was dead.
Did I go this way?
No, I did.
I don't know.
It looked like he died.
What does he look like?
Oh, they're cool.
Wait, they're pretty neat and remastered.
It's just so bright.
I don't know why it's...
It's weird that it's so bright.
Covenant, on the landing above us.
Firing!
I'm on your side!
Is he dead yet?
Wait, he's not dead!
You guys promised me I could kill them!
What is he for you, you're bad!
Come on, who needs something?
Why is he still alive?
No, don't you.
I was promised that they would die!
I mean...
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Just throw all of this...
Right here.
Wait, I think they're all dead.
As in my teammates are dead.
Whoops.
My bad.
There we go.
Hello?
Oh, there's a scope?
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
Why is the scope for the sensitivity so high?
There you go.
That's right.
Can't get me.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, so I might have killed...
My teammates.
I am the hero that humanity deserves.
I am the hero.
That's right.
That's how Master Chief kept surviving.
If I kill everybody, I'll be the only survivor.
Alright.
Go to Skulls tab.
The reason that Remastered textures are so bright is because they were reused from Halo Reach, which had a lot of outdoor well-lit levels.
343 went the lazy route.
Aw, that's sad.
That sucks.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Peter.
No witnesses.
Everyone will think I'm the hero if I'm the only one that survives.
Wait.
I know what to do.
I can't see where they are.
At this point, it's a strat.
Oh, I see you.
I...
Guys, I need...
I need to use this texture.
Oh, you think I don't see you?
Look.
See...
Oh, you think I don't see you?
There we go.
Come on.
Peek me.
Actually, no, let me grab this.
There we go.
Jesus, you're so tanky.
Alright.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa, little guy.
Get out of here!
Oh, wait, hello.
Which one?
Which gun?
This one?
Wait.
Oh, I like this one.
Wait, this one's nice.
Should I grab this one or...?
I'll grab this.
Wait, I like this gun.
Hello?
Any other aliens?
Aliens?
Don't go?
Yeah, you took one for the team.
Actually, it's the tab.
Wait, no, not the left!
Okay, they're a little... they're a little bit dumb.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, there it is.
I'm here.
I'm here, Cortana.
Oh.
That's a tight-knit corridor.
Not here?
Cortana, where do I go?
Oh, this way.
Oh, it's a maze.
Oh.
What's that?
What's the sound, guys?
Is the sound okay so far?
I see it.
Oh.
Oh, shit!
The fuck was that?
Yeah.
That's right.
Here I am.
Oh, no.
Come on, come over here.
Open that door.
That's right.
There's a shotgun?
Oh, shit!
I think you'll get closer!
You're crazy!
You're fucking crazy!
You got closer!
What's wrong with you?
Oh, bring up the game volume?
Okay.
I'll bring up the game volume a little.
For you guys...
Here, and then I'll put up the music a little bit more.
Alright.
Oh, I can charge it?
Wait, no I can't.
How do I charge this?
I don't think this is the one where you can charge.
I'm playing heroic.
Oh my god, I'm lost.
Oh my god.
15 meters to what?
Where am I?
Where the fuck...
Where did I come from?
Okay, I came from here.
Okay.
And then...
This is where I could go.
Oh my god.
Everything looks the same.
My little mini-map doesn't explain anything.
Here?
No, this is...
No, this is the vent.
This is the vent that I was in.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
How am I still here?
Okay.
Wait, I can't get out?
Wait, what?
I'm trapped?
Hello?
Knock, knock!
Where did I go?
I went backwards.
Where did I come from, chat?
I...
I killed so many!
How did you guys navigate this?
What was this?
Just all you hear is B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B.
Where did I come from?
Can I jump?
Where is that?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Cryo B.
Okay, I had to look down.
I figured it out.
Oh, I read the instructions on the floor.
The South Rifle has a little arrow on the arm, which should point towards your current objective.
Thank you to the Super Chat, Airborne.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, oh.
What the fuck are they doing now?
Okay, we gotta go down.
Thank you, arrows.
Thank you, arrows!
Oh shit, I can't.
Oh my god, I burned my hands.
I burned my hands!
Oh no.
My shields!
My hands!
Okay.
I wanna make sure that... I'm safe here.
Okay, nice.
Oh!
It just exploded randomly!
Okay.
There you go.
I don't think he knew.
I knew you didn't see it.
Oh my god, people!
Oh my god, humans!
Did I get the secret?
Is that...
Is that five?
That's five, right?
Toki, no.
You guys said I get a cool secret, but I killed five!
That's five!
No hesitation.
Toki, what the hell?
I wanna see my cool secret!
Oh my god, they're so scared.
They're so, like, timid.
Like, what's that?
Okay.
I said nothing.
You know what you said!
You said there'd be a cool secret!
I'm here for my cool secret!
That was not one guy!
You're like, no, he's right!
I saw you said he was right!
Hello?
Anybody here?
All right, this way.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Wait, is there someone over here?
No.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure I don't get fucking flanked.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, I thought I died!
I thought I died!
Get in here!
I need one more to make fit five!
Oh wait, how many of you?
One, two, three, four, five!
I need one more!
And then it will be five!
We're gonna make it, aren't we, sir?
I don't want to lie on you!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
But thank you, thank you!
I can't believe my O'Shea war crowned her own comrades!
In front of the official insignia for the red cross!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
But thank you, thank you!
Finally, my family of five is here!
The secret is that they shoot now!
Spare the tiny green men, I beg you!
Halo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hahaha!
If I still had fingers, they'd be crossed!
This guy's like, please stop shooting them!
They have families!
Okay, the sound balancing for...
The Halo...
Like, remaster for this is, like, pretty ass, I'll say that!
I'll raise it up!
Wait, how many?
One, two, three!
Are you guys...?
Oh...
Yeah, no, they definitely look dead-dead...
Hahaha!
Yeah, they definitely look dead...
No!
My five kills!
Alright, let's...
Let me raise the...
There's nothing we can do!
Alright, I'll put it at a hundred and see if that fixes it.
Alright...
I still have...
Aww!
I don't have...
Get to keep my alien gun!
What does it look like?
Ooh!
What's so bright?
Whoa!
Okay!
Okay, we'll go this way.
I guess, like...
We gotta find five more.
I assume I have to go across from here, right?
Yeah, I heard...
Pistol's the best weapon.
Alright, and thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
For just one dollar!
You can donate!
To support your local marines and keep them safe from...
Don't eat abuse!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, wait!
That looks like the enemy!
It's hard to go up.
Wait, what the fuck?
It made a child!
Whoa!
What's shooting me?!
What the fuck?!
It can shoot me?!
Oh my god, this is bullshit!
I have to fight a plane?!
Oh my god, it shoots back!
Are you serious?
Are you seri- Oh my god, bro.
I'm barely a person right now.
I'm like one tiny fly in your- In your world.
Okay.
Yeah.
There we go.
I don't wanna deal with these guys.
These guys are annoying.
No, I have shields.
These guys are so annoying.
I just have to play cover.
There we go.
Give me your gun.
Is this a- Okay, yeah.
These are the good one.
Nice and naked.
What the fuck?!
How are you alive?!
I killed your entire family!
Get out of here!
Pistol whip!
All right.
Come where I'll find the rest of your family.
I'm sorry.
Betty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fame, thank you for the super chat.
Anyone else in the chat playing along with Doki at the same time?
Thank you for the stream, boss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, did anyone survive?
Oh wait, that does...
Who's shooting back at me?
Oh my god, is this shit.
Wait, is there five of them?
Let's get rid of the tiny guys first.
And then we'll help them out.
Alright, where's the big guy?
Oh shit, he turned back!
I didn't think he'd turn back!
I was trying to do a flank!
Medic!
Good to see you, sir!
Welcome to the party!
No problem.
It's a mess, sir.
We're scouting all over this valley.
We called for evac, but until you showed up, I thought we were cooked.
Don't worry, Sergeant.
We'll stay here until evac arrives.
Heads up!
Alright, no problem.
No, I'm taking it!
Sorry!
I just... How was I supposed to know he could die from one singular pistol whip!
I didn't kill Johnson!
He's right here!
I made sure to... Make sure to keep him alive!
I kept him alive!
Guys, look, I did one good thing.
I get one.
You're super silky.
You should've made more!
It's not my fault!
Oh my god, I thought it'd be further.
Not gonna lie.
Come on.
Okay.
Wait, what's shooting me?
Oh my god, he's right here.
I'm dead.
I'm actually dead.
I'm so low.
I'm so low right now.
Oh my god.
Look, see, they're all alive.
Look, Johnson!
Sergeant Johnson alive!
Look at him go!
Oh.
Oh, wait, that's... Oh, fuck.
Sergeant Johnson.
Oh, no!
Sergeant Johnson, wake up!
Wake up, Sergeant Johnson!
Wake up!
You were clearly very important to the story!
I thought he
was...
Yeah, it's me.
He'll be back, right, guys?
Guys, where's the medic?
Guys!
Medic!
Oh my god.
Got him!
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, you can get... you can kill him if you want.
I really don't care enough.
Oh my god.
I hear them.
I hear these little fuckers running around.
Get out of here.
Get out!
He was the medic!
Oh, hey!
That's a new gun!
New gun!
Oh, wait.
It dropped.
It died.
Wait.
Me?
There's only me and you.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You're so...
Over here!
Oh my god!
There's health here!
Thank god.
Wait.
There's armor and health up top?
I don't need that, though.
Jesus!
There's so many!
Alright.
Wait.
Oh my god!
The ship is still shooting me?!
Okay.
Where's the last guy?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Get out of here!
Alright.
There we go.
There's still more?!
Where are they?!
What the?!
You are dead?!
How many are there?!
Who and her?
It's just me and him!
There it is!
I'm actually the last man alive.
No witnesses.
What do you mean it's my fault?!
I did everything I could.
I didn't even kill him.
I wanted to.
I restrained myself.
Like, shoot his fucking hands or some shit?
I did my best.
I'm alive.
What?
Thank you.
More lifeboats?
Wait.
Nice.
That's good.
We have reinforcements.
Wait.
Are they gonna drive away?
Oh, no.
Oh.
Okay, I can do this.
I can do this.
Alright, I believe in you.
Oh, no.
I don't know where to go.
Where am I?
Sir, where am I supposed to drive?
Is that Cliff?
Oh, down here.
Okay.
I must be here.
If there is a road, there is a way.
Will he drive for me?
Okay.
Drive.
That's right.
I shoot.
Drive!
Okay.
I guess I'll drive.
Get in the car!
Oh, my God.
He doesn't drive anymore.
Hey.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
Are you leaving?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Wait.
I don't think this is the right...
Wait, this is the right path.
There it is.
How did I honk the horn?
That's right.
Watch this.
Where am I?
The fuck is this place?
This...
What is this?
Where...
Where am I?
The dialogue?
Yeah, I don't know how to fix it.
The...
Whoa.
Whoa!
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
I don't know where I am.
I'm in this weird portal.
There's so many people.
No.
Back up.
Back...
Go.
Shoot him.
Holy fuck.
I almost drove off.
But I'm okay.
I'm okay, everyone.
I'm okay.
So close.
It's okay.
We're all okay.
There it is.
Where the fuck is this area?
I don't think I'm supposed to be here.
Nice and smooth now.
Come get some.
I'll slowly run over...
Run them over.
Come and take your medicine.
Alright, nice.
I am?
Where do I go after here?
I killed them all.
Oh, maybe...
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Worth it.
It's so worth it.
Alright, I gotta get out.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Okay.
There we go.
It has to be here.
There's something over here that I can't go through.
What?
Okay, there we go.
We're okay.
Nope, I parked my car.
We should be good.
Alright.
Let's press this button.
Button press.
Oh, I know it's speed when we're up with the car, apparently.
For the last level or something.
I saw it on the...
Uh, SGDDQD...
BCD...
Where...
Where you can get...
Use the car to do the...
The speed run or some shit.
For the last level.
Oh my god, now I can cross.
Don't worry, I parked my car.
There's fall...
Okay.
At least now I know there's fall damage.
Um...
Let's hope...
Let's...
Okay.
Wait.
Wait, okay.
Okay, wait.
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Everything...
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
It's a little tight, but it's okay.
We got...
Yay!
It's low...
It's lowly and steady.
We did it.
Yay!
I wonder if there's a way to boost the vol...
The dialogue up.
A lot more crew made it off the autumn than I had predicted.
I have to not drive the hero.
Okay.
We can find...
We're gonna find the survivors.
We have a chance to coordinate an effective resistance.
I wonder if there's a way to boost up the...
I feel like the game volume...
The game volume and the...
Uh...
I feel like the effects volume in the voice chat...
Yeah.
The...
That's crazy.
Okay.
Maybe the effects...
If I lower the effects...
Maybe?
Because I think...
The game volume is tied to the...
Game...
The...
The dialogue.
Okay.
Maybe that's how we can do it.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This is so...
This is so clunky.
The trap.
Reunion tour?
We're reunioning with?
They're all dead.
Oh menu music is tied to the cutscene music?
Okay.
I'll do that.
Sorry guys.
I'm sorry for the lack of...
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Ba-dam.
Wait.
Where are you guys seeing the lifeboat?
Oh shit.
That car won't brake, right?
What's that?
What is that?
Where are they seeing the light...
Oh, is it behind me?
Oh!
Is it quieter?
There's no way.
Effects is tied?
Oh my god, it is!
The effects and the...
That's crazy!
Okay, that's actually fucking weird.
Is it behind me?
I don't see the lifeboat.
Oh!
There we go.
Oh wait, there's something up here.
What's up here?
There's beacon lights here.
What's over here?
There's people.
Don't worry!
I'm a hero!
Oh shit!
Don't worry, the hero's here!
Oh my god!
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to...
Oh hey, here's...
Oh!
Don't die!
I'm trying my best!
This is very, very...
Okay, let me get out of here.
Alright, don't die.
Don't die while I get ammo from these dead bodies.
Yay.
Alright.
Does anyone see us?
Yeah, I see you guys!
How do I get up here?
Hello!
It's him!
That's me!
I'm John Halo!
Alright!
Yeah, it's me!
There's a lifeboat?
Where is he?
Is he up here?
Hello!
Is that you?
Oh, is that him?
Wait, if I kill him, do I get a sniper?
Cool.
You could have got one for free!
But okay!
Guys, but I got a coin sniper!
Watch this!
Ooh!
Okay.
Nice.
I saw nothing.
Wait, but where is the lifeboat?
Where is it?
Wait, is my car okay?
Oh, it's that thing!
Whoops.
It's okay, now I have two.
Guys, it's good.
Because now...
That's...
That's okay.
Because now...
Guys, now...
Now I can get more sniper ammo.
And where I believe my team will be okay.
Oh, he's dead.
No, he's okay.
There it is.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
I got more sniper ammo.
Look at that!
Now I got...
Now I got more sniper ammo, guys.
Are you guys all safe now?
Now I have more sniper ammo.
I'm not...
Guys!
Just one guy.
What?
I also make sure there's no witnesses.
There's always been five.
We could also make sure...
He died...
Exactly.
He died for...
Okay.
My gunner is definitely dead.
I may or may not have actually got him killed there.
I...
Wait!
Nice shot.
Here we go.
Okay.
I think I got all of them.
See, there's always...
Wait, he's back!
Look!
See, I told you!
Look at that!
He didn't die!
I see him!
Look at that guy!
Oh!
No!
Oh no!
Sergeant Johnson!
No!
Not again!
Guys, he's napping.
Guys, Sergeant Johnson is just taking a long vacation.
He deserves it.
Guys, Sergeant Johnson has been through a lot, guys.
Oh no.
Where the fuck?
Oh, did I kill him?
Nice.
Taking another power nap.
It's okay.
Just taking a nap, guys.
This is a well-deserved vacation.
He's a hero, guys.
He's a fucking hero.
Alright.
We're fine.
See you guys?
We're a-okay.
What the fuck?
Okay.
See guys?
There's always been four.
Echo 419.
We read you Echo 419.
Okay.
Check it to- Cypher Society.
Proof for the science of super- For her.
Cause thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One near the cliff edge.
And another near the- Hey, you're going to wildfire at head level?
To see from my altitude bang.
I don't trust you.
I- I- Oh wait.
Look.
See?
Everybody's rescued.
I did it.
There's always been four.
For democracy.
For super-Earth.
Goodbye, my four survivors.
Goodbye.
I did it.
There's always been four.
It's always my- Oh, he's still alive!
Oh my god!
Now I have two of them!
Look at that!
God showed up.
But let's go.
Oh my god!
He found- He- Mitosis, guys!
I- I- Oh my god!
He fucking mitosis!
Hail it.
He made a new friend.
Oh nice, there's more ammo.
Thank god.
Who's one shot?
Wait, how do you know they're one shot?
How do you guys know that?
What does it say?
How do you guys- Oh, there we go.
No, I see it.
I see it.
Oh yeah, no.
He's definitely slow.
I don't give him- Can I give them HP?
Oops.
It's alright.
He'll live for like one- One day.
That's all I need.
Also, has the volume been up better?
I know the vo- Dialogue is really bad.
But like, I- I don't know how- There's no way to fix that.
Sorry, give me a sec.
Whoops.
Don't worry, I can fix this.
Wait.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Get in.
Get in guys.
No, okay.
Guys.
Okay.
I don't want my gunner to be the one with zero HP.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, you should stay here.
Guys, stay here.
No, you are literally gonna die if I don't do anything about it.
Okay.
Alright, I gotta make sure these big guys are dead.
Alright, it's time.
Are you guys ready?
Alright, here we go.
More of them.
Go do your thing.
Back me up.
Give me a sec.
I gotta make sure I don't slam into this tree.
I'm doing it.
Oh!
Alright.
Oh, I'm trying to- I'm trying to get over the hills!
Oh my god, there's the marines.
Alright.
You guys got this.
We've got wounded here.
I'll call in and drop ship to pick them up.
Don't worry, I got you!
Damn it, they're everywhere!
Lay those!
I see them!
Alright, nice.
Okay, and then we get rid of the tiny guys.
Alright, you stay here!
I believe!
Is that it?
What was that?
Wait, no, there's two over here.
Alright, now he's dead.
Hey!
Thanks, guys.
I know.
Alright, we gotta wait for- We gotta wait for a ship.
Oh, I can?
How do I zoom in a second time?
Oh wait, is it the sniper?
Over here!
Oh, okay, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, I'm not used to zooming in a second time, clearly.
Oh, you like that?
I'm not used to it.
Here we go.
Okay, now it's just the babies.
I have that one!
No, you did not!
I- the closer they are, the- the harder it was to shoot them, apparently.
Over
here!
Yeah!
We're going to look for the last lifeboat, Echo 419.
Oh, I have to find one more person.
Wow!
It's taller than I thought.
Oh my god!
Wait!
No, there's no Sergeant Johnson.
Look, I did it, guys.
I'm a hero.
I told you I can save everyone.
He did die!
I did it!
Careful, everyone.
She's a hero.
Okay.
I need to figure out where the last one is.
Give me a sec.
There's more rifle?
Alright, you guys will be safe.
I trust you guys.
I need more- I need more sniper rifle ammo.
Where would it be?
There's ammo by this rock?
This one?
Guys, this entire area is just rocks.
You gotta be more specific.
Which rock?
Oh, this rock!
Is it because he's dead?
I know.
You only got my- Thank you for your service.
Alright.
There you go.
Where did I park my car?
There I did.
Alright.
This is an- It's an honorable teabag, guys.
I gave him what he's always wanted.
What the?
What?
You can't hide from me!
Roger that!
There's more?
Oh my god.
There might be more ammo here.
Alright.
Let me grab this real quick.
Give me a sec, man.
Gotta grab some more ammo.
Go!
Oh shit, never mind.
Wrong way.
Alright.
Get back in here.
Get in here!
Guys!
Oh nice, they swapped places.
That's good.
Where else would they be?
Alright.
Go back up.
Oh, with the last...
Oh, I- I didn't kill that guy?
Okay, there we go.
Nah, I killed that guy.
I'm missing one more area.
Morning.
I picked up reports that the Covenant has located and secured the Pillar of Autumn's crash site.
Oh, there's lights here!
Alright.
That has to be the last one.
Oh!
Wait, no, didn't I go here?
Was I here before?
I think so.
I don't remember.
Okay, let's try this area.
I'm lost again.
Yeah, this is where I- I rescued four people.
Yeah, it was here.
Okay, I went here already.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I- I- The one where I rescued all four of them.
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
It's over here!
I see it.
This was the first area I didn't go to.
Wee!
Whoops.
Don't worry, y'all.
It's still alive.
Why are you complaining?
You're both still alive!
Look, if you think you're such a good driver, why don't you drive this?
Come on, Florida!
There's always been four.
Okay, it's this way.
Right here.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I shall run you over!
Ah!
That's right!
Get back here!
Oh, okay.
I mean, that works too.
Yeah, man!
But there's nothing here.
Wait, that's just a cliff.
So, maybe I am.
Wait!
No, I haven't been here!
Here, here!
This is it!
This is where I haven't been!
That's right!
Oh!
Right?
Let me run you over into that rock!
I figured it out, guys.
Now I know I'm in the right area.
No, I'm not blind!
I figured it out!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
There's an arrow down!
Oh, thank god!
Okay!
I figured...
Oh, there!
Missed!
The one hole!
Okay, sorry.
I missed the hole!
Oh, no!
They got...
They added a marker!
Oh my god!
Okay!
It was the one hole that I was missing.
Okay, now I figured it out.
Okay.
More of a way!
Okay, now we go for it.
Okay, things will be okay.
We got...
Woo!
That's a wrap!
Alright.
We just gotta...
Okay, we gotta...
Find a parking spot, man!
We gotta find a parking spot!
Right here!
A little parking spot!
That's fine!
Oh, shit.
Here we go.
Hello.
Get...
Get out of here!
Alright.
Nice.
How the fuck did you dodge that?
Wait.
What?
Oh my...
I grazed his ear!
Here we go.
Come on.
Oh my god.
That shit actually grazed his ear.
I'm so sad.
We should search the interior of those structures before we leave.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Nice.
I mean, I have a lot of nades.
Ew.
Alright.
I couldn't bring my car down with me.
Oh my god.
I almost shot them.
I've called for an evac.
Roger that.
Hey guys.
Marines!
Assemble for evac.
Pronto!
I'm here to help you.
Oh fuck!
What the fuck?
They just shoot each other!
Oh my god.
Oh no.
There's nothing over here!
Okay.
I sort of accidentally naded myself guys.
I...
I might have naded myself there.
That's...
That's on me.
That's on me guys.
That's...
Yeah.
I deserve that.
I noticed that I naded myself and I knew it was over.
Are you not following me?
Okay.
They are.
That's good.
Are you...
Come over here guys!
Men!
Come over here!
I parked my car!
Right here men!
Oh my god.
Please.
I parked my car.
Come...
Get over here!
I parked my car right here!
Please!
I'm right here!
Get over here!
Oh my god.
How did...
Do I need to clear the area first?
And then you'll be happy?
Okay.
God they're so fucking stupid.
They're so dead.
They're not gonna live guys.
They're so stupid.
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
I'm gonna take you to war.
You're gonna get your stripes today!
You're gonna get your stars today men!
Oh what?
Yeah.
No shit!
Welcome to war!
See?
They're not so tough.
Oh yeah!
Where's the others?
Oh they're over here.
Stick together!
Oh my god.
That guy is so brave.
Okay.
That's a grunt.
There's no way you'd die to a grunt guys.
What the hell am I doing here?
Alright.
Welcome to war!
Cadets!
There's like one below me somewhere.
He's like running around like a little baby.
Oh there he is.
He was inside.
There we go.
That should be the last one right?
That's the last of them.
Yeah.
Roger that.
I'm on my way.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
I found Captain Keyes.
He's being held on a Covenant cruiser.
The Truth and Reconciliation.
A ship I disabled before we abandon the auto.
I did it.
The Truth and Reconciliation.
Touchdown on a desert plateau.
Roughly 300 kilometers up spin.
Hey.
This is where I parked my car.
Alright.
I saved them.
Alright man.
Come over here and escape.
I worked very hard to secure your safety.
Get aboard and let's get out of here.
Oh.
I get to leave?
Yay.
Yippee.
Bye.
Yay.
I did it.
Mission complete.
I saved everybody.
Everyone.
Yippee.
They all live.
Captain Keyes.
And are holding him aboard one of their cruisers.
Okay.
So I have to save Captain Keyes.
The ship is currently holding position.
Okay.
That's easy.
There was always four.
Heh heh heh heh.
There's a gravity lift that varies troops and supplies between the ship and the surface.
That's our ticket in.
Once we get inside the ship, I should be able to lock onto the tracking signal from Captain Keyes neural implants.
Okay.
I have to rescue Captain Keyes.
Wait.
Sergeant Johnson lived!
See I told you guys!
He was just taking a nap!
I told you!
He was just napping!
I recommend using your sniper rifle to take out the gunners while I call the marine support.
Whoops.
Ha ha ha.
Oops.
Ha ha ha ha.
Don't let him get away!
I didn't.
I may or may not have let him finish talk.
May I should have finished hearing him talk first.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, whoops.
Oh no.
Okay.
That was an accident.
Ha ha ha.
Wait.
I don't get a pistol?
I didn't know we were supposed to stop!
There we go.
Guys, I didn't know it was an accident!
No!
Okay, I think a lot of my men are dead.
Ha ha ha ha!
I think...
I think a lot...
Oh my god, I can't see.
I had to put it on remastered.
Enemy!
Yeah, the strat.
If I can't see...
All I do...
Okay, if I can't see...
All I...
Wait.
I need to grab the lead pistol.
What are the leads that killed?
Here it is.
Or if I can't see...
Bam!
That's right!
I can see now.
There we go.
It's called the... the remaster strat.
Yeah, I could use a flashlight, but like... I could also do... BAM!
Oh, shit!
Meat shields!
Wait, where's Sergeant Johnson?
Guys, we're Sergeant...
Guys, we're Sergeant Johnson, guys!
Oh, wait, he's still alive?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
Oh, I shoved.
That was my bad.
Yeah, hombre!
Oh, my god, these little stupid little babies!
Oh, I need more ammo!
You better be fucking sorry!
Ow!
What the
fuck?!
Who the fuck shot me?!
I'm with you!
I don't have ammo.
Okay.
Guys, sneak up around!
Hey, good one!
Okay.
What
happened?!
A sneak up on...
Okay, that's not on me!
That was not on me, guys!
Okay, I hear it.
There we go.
Oh, no!
I need to kill another Lee and steal his pistol!
Oh, shit!
I didn't think they're all there!
Woo!
Woooo!
No!
It's okay, we can do this again, guys.
Remember, we gotta sneak in, guys.
Guys, we gotta sneak in, everybody.
Covering fire!
I- why did you shoot?
God, I can't see.
It's remastered time.
Okay, that was pretty sick, though.
Okay,
I don't think they saw me.
There we go.
I think I killed him.
Peekaboo!
Okay, I think they're dead.
Can I crouch jump that?
Wait, can I?
Let's try.
No.
I can't do crouch jump for that.
No, I did!
I did crouch jump!
See?
It doesn't let me crouch jump this!
I- I know my crouch jumps!
I'm playing TTT!
Oh my god, there's a tree right here.
Did I kill him?
I can't tell.
Okay, there we go.
How are they getting shot at?
Guys, what's going on?
What the fuck is going on over there?
What the fuck are you doing over there?
Oh my god, okay.
I didn't hit myself.
That's good.
Oh my god, that stupid shield.
Okay, my team's dead.
I don't know what the fuck my team was doing, but they're dead.
Where's the rest of them?
Oh wait, they're not dead!
They're not dead, guys!
You're live!
Where are you?
Yeah, they're dead.
Look at that, we did it.
We did it, everybody!
They rushed a B.
Oh my god, that's fine.
That's fine.
Alright, I need a fucking fine elite gun.
I need a swap guns.
Where are the elites?
I know I killed some elites here!
Where are they?
Look, I was desperate, okay?
I...
Get over here.
They're mad that I used my regular gun.
Oh my god, thank god!
Finally!
Okay, we have a real gun now.
I have active camouflage.
Oh nice.
Okay, now I have ammo.
I did it.
Didn't clear everybody?
No, there's people here.
Where are they?
Oh my god, there they are.
Oh shit!
Okay, I didn't realize all of them were gonna show up there.
Get outta here!
Oh no, sorry!
Sorry!
I can't!
He's in us!
He's in the team!
I've had enough of this crap!
What are you thinking?
What do you mean?
I just shot my gun!
We're directly under the ship now.
Okay, I want...
Where the fuck is the elite gun?
Eh?
Is that all of them?
Any elites?
Okay, there's one.
All right, get out of here.
Let's do it!
All right, get out.
Oh, it's a time thing!
Okay.
Okay, I know that now.
I know it's time now.
Because I was like so confused.
Oh, is it homing?
Oh, it is!
Nice!
I like that.
Where is it?
Okay, nice.
Get outta here.
Get outta here!
Oh shit!
Oh, I didn't realize there were more.
That's okay.
I have this.
Oh fuck, nevermind!
Oh god!
Oh my god, the reload!
Oh shit, I'm sorry!
Got
confused!
Oh, I'm one HP.
I have to hit seven needles for it to explode?
Okay, now I know.
I'll just spam it.
There we go.
That's not overkill, right?
Guys, it's not overkill, guys.
They deserve that.
They absolutely deserve it.
Here we go.
Jesus, how many are there?
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep throwing.
Nades.
Here we go.
That's fine.
I have this.
I don't have this.
I need a new gun.
It's okay.
I have this now.
There we go.
I'm so sad.
My own teammates naded me.
Yeah.
Damn right, it's your fucking fault.
Damn fucking right.
I can't believe he shot.
I can't believe it.
Shot by my own teammates.
The marines.
No one.
What did I do?
I don't know what they're talking about.
I did nothing.
I was a good soldier.
A good soldier knows how to follow orders.
I can't believe it.
I can't, I can't believe they did that to me.
I didn't deserve that.
You do it.
You do- There's only one.
There's only one left.
I've made sure let's... let's survive this time.
I've made sure of that.
Get out of here.
Now it's just me.
Now... now it's just me.
As it should be.
I'm fine with that.
No!
Get me out of here!
Just do it.
Stop shooting yourself!
Alright, it's fine.
We go up?
I don't know if I should...
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Wait, what?
Oh, I do not have enough ammo for that.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
Holy shit!
Okay, it's dead.
Are these hunters?
Okay, now we can go up.
Once we're inside the ship, I can home in on the captain's command...
Okay, we can get captain keys now.
Beam me up, Scott.
No, I'm not heroic.
Oh?
Why is there no covenant?
Yeah.
Maybe nobody's home.
But they sent...
Did they send their entire family to kill me?
Oh!
They're invisible!
Oh no, I have no nades.
I have no nades.
You have no covenant.
You have to open your mouth.
Oh my god, they're invisible now.
Run!
Oh my god, they have nades!
Look at them fly!
I see you.
It's glowing.
Oh!
It's fine.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
No!
It's one shot!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, they're running blind!
Oh my...
Please.
Give me your gun.
Give me...
No!
I think...
He has to die!
Why are they so much...
Oh my god, he just killed my men!
No!
Don't let him kill me!
Please!
Okay.
I just didn't have another gun.
I had to wait for my men to die before I could...
Okay, thank god he died.
Thank god.
Okay.
Thank fucking god.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
It's okay.
We needed him to die.
That's good that he died.
You don't understand.
We ran out of ammo.
We had to let him die.
Oh my god.
They are everywhere.
They are.
Nice.
Okay.
I have enough ammo now.
Back me up.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're fine now.
No, you did not.
You know you did not.
I hear.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
If he dies, it's okay.
We need more ammo.
We need all the ammo.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh no.
Okay.
I hear.
I hear him.
But where?
Go roar.
Behind me.
Okay.
No, let me have the... No, I need him to die!
I got it!
No!
He has to kill my men.
I need the gun!
I'm almost softlocked.
I need them to, like... I'm actually almost softlocked.
No, I'm trying to find... Where is the gun?!
I can't!
Every time I use the gun!
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go!
We did it!
We did it, guys!
I tried to melee him!
He just... He does so much!
I swear to God!
Meleeing him was the first thing I did!
We lived, we lived for so long, dude.
That's the worst part.
Oh, no!
I have no HP!
I gotta hear him!
Fear!
Absolute fear!
I'm one HP!
No!
Oh my god.
Why did it work?
WHY DID IT WOR-
Lise, please get me out of here!
Where's my teammate... what?!
Hot down to me!
Please get me out of here.
Lise, somebody get me out of here!
No, no, no.
No, no... Where's your dead body?!
Where's your dead body?!
Oh, thank God!
Ok, ok!
I'm okay!
Now, I'm okay!
Now!
I'm okay!
Ok.
Now!
Oh, my God.
It's fine!
Oh, my God, I found!
I found!
Oh, my God.
I'm not OK?
Oh, my God, I'm not OK!
Okay.
Oh, I'm not okay.
I am not okay, guys.
I'm so scared.
Oh, please have mercy.
Get out of here.
Get out.
I had to reload!
Oh, my God!
Where's
your gun?
Where's your gun?
I see one.
Contact!
Lots of contact!
Oh,
my God!
Why did I use it all?
Why?
Oh, I'm one.
I'm one.
I'm okay.
It's you and me.
Okay.
I'll stay here.
Oh, I can't stay here.
Imagine if... No!
No!
Oh,
I think he sees me.
I think he saw me.
I'm fucking stuck in a loop.
Let me out of here!
Where is it?
Here we go.
We got it.
Nice one.
Okay.
We're okay.
We're okay for now.
Wait.
I hear him.
I hear
him.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
OHHH, it's okay!
Oh my god, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
I was panicking!
I'm also scared.
Don't worry, buddy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That's right!
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, I have no ammo.
Okay.
I'll be over here.
That should do something, right?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, it's fine.
We're so healthy.
Alright, I'll just stay here.
It's fine.
Oh my God, I have no ammo.
It's not fine.
I ran out of ammo for all my guns.
It's fine.
Okay.
No, fuck it.
You guys deserve this.
Please, I just, please, I just want to be out of this hell.
Please.
I don't want to be here anymore.
Get me out of here!
Oh, no!
Alright.
Okay.
Are we... Is it over?
Is it over?
Oh my God, I hear you.
Oh my God, no ammo.
What do you mean?
I don't think he knows.
I don No!
It's fine.
Oh my god, it's so fine.
We... are we okay?
Hello?
Oh!
Is everybody dead?
Oh my god!
We made it!
We fucking made it!
Oh my god!
We didn't find a fire!
You can tap fire in a... Which one is the plasma?
I've lost track of everything.
There's a help back!
Oh my god, where is it?
Oh, okay.
Okay, gotta explore.
Gotta calm down.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
I'll use that.
Oh my god, there's a... Oh my god, there's a help back.
Thank god.
Okay, everything is okay.
Everything is okay now.
No, that sniper is the one I threw away, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, that was the one I threw away.
Oh...
Okay, we did it.
We made it.
We made it through the next room.
Um...
Okay.
God, I need this.
Oh my god!
I don't think they know I'm here.
Okay, I don't think they know.
Nice.
Okay, this way.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure I nade all of this so he doesn't fucking bother me.
Alright.
One more.
Wait, who's below me?
What the fuck?
I can't see.
Don't worry.
I can see now.
My shields!
That's fine.
I'm going with recharge shields.
He was tearing it back.
Guys, I couldn't see!
Okay.
Oh my god, they have so much HP!
Like
that!
That's fucking right!
That's right, you should have moved!
That's what you get!
Oh, I thought there was somebody to my left.
Okay.
Oh my god, no, not my shields.
Okay, they do like...
They do like P damage on me, so it's fine.
It's these guys I have to worry about.
They do like two pick damage.
That's it.
I'm getting these guys out.
Okay, I shouldn't peek though.
I just realized...
I need to wait for my shield recharge.
Okay, nice.
Now I can look.
No!
My fucking battery!
Okay.
Alright, I don't need to kill them.
Never mind, I'm gonna leave.
Fuck this, I'm leaving.
I realized I didn't have to kill them anyway.
There's no point.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Alright.
Hurry up.
Guys, why did I use all my sniper rifle?
Why?
Why did nobody warn me?
No way!
He dodged it?
That's fucking right.
Okay, I like this gun.
And this was my favorite gun.
From the aliens.
Okay.
I know, like, I know I should just shoot it when you're not using the shield, but, like, I can't be bothered, guys.
I actually can't be bothered.
Fuck this.
Alright.
Are we good?
Are we safe now?
I don't detect any...
I detect motion.
Alright.
Oh, wait!
Oh, you're still alive!
That's just your shield!
Oh my god, I see the grenade.
I see the grenade, guys.
How do you get baited this time?
Where you going, little buddy?
That's fucking right.
You think you can... you can run away?
I wanted to run away, and look what that got me.
Now I'm in a fucking war!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Oh, sh- What!
He's sticky-boreed me like a whore!
I can't do anything about it!
That's messed up.
The fact that I can't do anything about it.
I just gotta live with it.
I see you.
I fucking see you.
I see you!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, no.
That's right.
I saw you.
I saw you behind me.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
What?
Oh, there you are.
What the fuck?
It didn't show up in my movement.
I only have 16 bullets, guys.
Okay, never mind.
I have 88 now.
All right.
Oh, there's more.
Okay, it's just the babies, though.
I'm not as scared.
It's just the babies.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Mommy's trying to play a game.
Okay, this way.
Alright.
That's good.
He's not using his shield.
The one defense he has, he's not using it.
Get out of here.
That's right.
You think I'm gonna take cover?
Oh shit, I'll take cover.
Oh wait, never mind.
Never mind.
You're right, I will.
I just noticed who it was.
I thought that was like, not, not the elites.
Word, word, word.
You have?
Okay.
I need new ammo.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared of the hunters, guys.
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Reinforcements.
Oh shit.
Where's the reinforcements?
I was told reinforcements.
Where are they?
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
Stand in front of the bullets.
Yes.
Reinforcements stand in front of it.
Take it all.
Thank god.
Thank god for reinforcements.
How do I like, get above, though?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Wait, I think my art, my team's dying.
That's fine.
That's okay.
My reen- oh, my entire reinforcements are dead, guys.
Guys.
Guys, they're all dead.
Um.
Guys.
I don't know what happened.
They all just died.
What the fuck happened?
They're all dead.
What happened?
It sounded so epic.
The music was so epic.
How do I get up?
You just walked away.
I don't know, I thought they- Okay, I need to restart this.
Kill me now.
I already lost all my shield.
It's not worth it.
It's not.
Yeah, how could they die after such an epic music?
Requesting reinforcements at our position.
I don't understand.
Okay.
I have to reset my shields.
Right here.
Okay.
I don't know how they just died.
They don't get- I thought they would get the music buff.
It sounded so cool and everything.
And then they were just dead.
I don't know what happened to them.
It was so cool.
Oh no.
Oh no, I need to grab this.
Here we go.
Where are they getting shot from?
Oh my god, that's where they're getting shot from.
Okay.
Oh no, no battery.
That burns!
I'm trying my best!
They have high ground!
Okay.
I'm trying, I'm trying to find an energy gun!
But there are none!
Probably burn!
They just- He's just rolling!
I'm trying to nade him!
And all they do is roll!
Oh my god, you can't use the cover forever.
Oh, I'm gonna suppress fire!
Jesus Christ!
I don't know where the kneeler is!
Oh my god, there we go.
Are they all dead?
Oh, we did it!
Okay, we did it, guys!
Look at that!
Wait, what?
Oh, guys, we did not do it.
Guys, we did not do it.
There's more.
We all- I thought we did it, guys!
I lied!
There's more!
Oh, I got this!
What?!
Why did you- Team!
Team, you did not have to stand there, team!
Team, you did not have to all stand there!
Where are they?
I'm on it!
Hit the dirt!
Leave, leave!
Okay, we got one!
Come on.
We got more of the babies.
I see you.
Oh my god, there's so many of them!
Oh, well, they got the piece of you.
They definitely did.
Oh, they definitely got a piece of you, though.
Oh!
What the fuck?!
Teleport behind me?!
Holy shit!
They literally teleported behind me!
Oh my god, I accidentally hit myself.
I accidentally hit myself, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where's the needler?
Where's the needler when you need one?!
Okay.
Let's see.
Where did he go?
Where?
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god, where's... Oh, thank god.
Thank god, okay.
I have to get ammo.
Here we go.
We're having this very intense 1v1 right now.
It's fine!
Oh my god, it's fine!
It's so fine!
And it's not fine!
And it's not fine no more!
It is not... Oh, it is not fine no more!
It is not fine no more!
It's not fine no more!
It's not fine!
It's fine!
We're so fine!
I don't know where a needler is!
I can't find a needler!
Everyone just drops these stupid guns!
I haven't seen a single dealer!
I would if I could!
Okay.
All right.
Give me a sec, little one.
Let me find another gun.
Thank you.
There we go.
All right.
Now.
Okay.
Now we fight.
Get out of here!
Okay.
What?
There we go.
Oh shit!
You're not- You're not baby!
Okay.
We should be fine now.
Wait, one of you had a needler.
I saw it!
Alright.
We're just gonna hold on to that for now.
Actually, maybe we don't need the needler.
Not yet.
We'll be fine for now.
Oh my god!
We need the needler!
Wait, actually no.
These guys- These guys- I forgot.
These guys- We don't need the needler.
Hello?
Okay, nice.
Oh shit!
Oh, I just got rid of his shield.
I'm going to call for reinforcements.
There's no sense going in with anything less than full strength.
Cortana to foe hammer.
All right.
Additional support troops.
We do.
We're going to open the shuttle bay door again.
Please.
Send help!
SOS!
Oh no.
I'll stay here.
Goodbye!
Close door!
Hello?
Yeah, nice.
I gotta remember my energy level.
I'm just remembering my shields real quick.
Hello?
Give me a sec.
Come on, I know you want to peek.
I know you're here.
Come on!
Look at me in the eye!
Okay, nice.
I need your gun.
There we go.
I can't- I'm too scared.
The last time I tried to punch somebody, I died.
I was in a death loop.
I'm too scared, guys.
I don't want to go through that again.
Oh my god.
No, I need- Oh no.
Come on, recharge my shield!
Nice, my shield's recharged.
Oh nice, SOS!
It's Sergeant Johnson!
Oh man!
Welcome back, sir!
Welcome back!
That's- Oh my god.
Here we go.
Look at that.
See, I'm not afraid anymore.
There's a gun.
Oh, there's the gun.
I got Sergeant Johnson here.
Sergeant Johnson number four!
The fourth one.
The fourth one is juicier.
Now with more juice.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Look at this.
Oh, shit!
What is that?
Why is the poor- they- Why is that- I don't trust anything anymore.
Ok, checkpoint.
Oh shit!
Alright, I thought that... I thought there'd be more, you know?
I thought he'd be alive for a little longer.
What do you mean?
He was right here!
Oh, is that my shield rechar- Okay, I was so locked in, I never noticed that was the sound of my shield recharging.
Okay, I'm on the third floor now.
Keep it up!
Holy fuck.
What is this?
That's right, I did that.
That's right, you're welcome.
Oh, I feel like a hunter's gonna come up for it anytime soon.
For the invisible man!
I'm scared of the invisible man!
What the fuck?!
Hold your fire, I'm home!
When did these guys show up?!
Whoops, sorry.
Sorry, random marines.
That's the way to do it!
Alright.
Don't worry!
The ninja hunters.
Oh my god, I thought that was gonna hit me.
Alright, forward we go!
Mike, I can't see anything!
Oh, don't worry!
Just press tab!
Haha!
You can see everything in the remastered!
There we go!
Left, right.
I miss ya!
Wait, is there stuff here?
Oh!
I can't!
Yes!
Thank god people died here!
Thank god!
Where's Sergeant Johnson?
Oh my god!
It's empathy!
Haha!
What if they actually ran into my missile there?
When I did this?
What's that?
Captain Keys?
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, we were sleeping!
I- Ah!
Ah!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Why did you fire!
Why did you fire?
Keep it up!
What the fuck, Sergeant?
My fault!
Yes!
No wonder it was your fault!
Yes it is!
Bro, why can't my AI be like their AI?
Oh my god!
That was so bullshit!
That- Are you se- Men!
Men!
Please!
My men!
Why?
Oh my god!
Oh you- Please!
Don't stay from my- And now there was one!
Now- After all that!
Now there's one!
Here it is!
There's only one left!
There's always been one!
Oh!
Alright, let's go!
To the control center!
Oh!
That's not important?
Oh, I thought that'd be important!
Oh!
This is gonna be awkward!
They're gonna be like, what happened to reinforcements?
I don't know!
They like, threw a nade on themselves!
Like, I- There was nothing I could do!
There was-
I-I cannot stop them from themselves!
I'm sorry!
Alright!
I can't stop that!
What war- Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I don't have to fuck this one guy in particular!
That's rough, buddy!
There you go!
Alright!
I'm so fucked!
I assume it's this way, right?
We must be in the brig!
These look like holding cells!
Yeah!
There are probably multiple detention stations!
The captain must be in one of them!
We need to keep looking for him!
Alright!
Freedom!
Let them go!
What?
I can't freedom?
Hello?
Captain?
Are you in here?
How do you fire so fast?
Oh, I just- I just click it!
Just spam it!
It's just that- Wait!
Is that Johnson?
Johnson number five?
Bro!
Good!
You- You spawned and dead?
Okay!
At least we got meds though!
Just click really fast!
I played FPS games way too much, that's how.
Dude, that's the only reason why I clicked so fast.
I played a lot of FPS games.
Oh my god!
I see him!
He's like right over here!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
He's right there!
He's like literally right there!
Oh my god!
How many are there?
Stop!
Why are there so many of you?
That's right!
Are you mad?
Get mad!
I'm mad too!
No!
Alright!
Holy shit!
You're still alive!
Oh my god!
I've ran out!
I've ran out of ammo!
Don't worry!
I killed two more!
Just for this!
What?
Is that it?
I got them all?
I got them all!
Alright!
Freedom!
Keys?
Is that you?
Captain Keys!
You two know better than this!
Thanks!
Marines!
Lock and load your weapons!
Let's be ready to move!
We did it!
While the Covenant had us locked up in here, I overheard the guards talking about this ring world.
They call it...
Halo!
Halo drop!
John!
Halo!
That's me!
He said the thing!
Wait, he can understand?
They speak English?
Halo controls the fate of the universe.
Oh!
That's also something I know from Halo.
I have a new mission for you.
We need to beat the Covenant to Halo's control room.
Okay, so we gotta get Halo.
Let's move!
Yes, sir!
Okay, sir!
He's like, fort fort!
Fort fort!
Alright, I got you guys!
I think Keys is gonna die.
Guys, I don't know if I could protect Keys, guys!
Guys!
Knowing my track record, someone's gonna die!
I know my track record!
Someone is absolutely gonna die!
I hear him!
I hear ya!
Guys, I don't know if I could protect Keys, guys!
I don't know!
Is there anybody on the other side?
Okay, we have to go this side.
Okay, that's what...
At least now I know.
Okay, maybe I'll hit him?
Guys, please!
Please!
Guys, I'm trying to protect all of you guys!
Guys, please!
Okay, this way.
Okay.
Alright, I wanna get rid of the mini guys.
Get out of here, mini-mees!
Please!
Stop shooting me!
Oh my god!
Stop shooting your own men!
Okay, that was not my fault.
That was not my fault, guys.
I was...
They did that to themselves!
We saw it!
We all saw that happen!
I didn't do it!
I didn't do that!
Am I, like, backtracking?
You have to backtrack, right?
Guys, where do we go?
Where...
Oh!
I
didn't notice the glowing blue knives.
I didn't notice...
With these...
What did he kill?
Wait, did he kill Keyes?
Oh, you're fine.
Keyes is okay.
It's okay.
Keyes was the only one that lived.
Alright, there we go.
That's right, you sign up for this.
You wanted to go to space, didn't you?
You thought Earth was boring.
You sign up for this.
Oh.
Turn around, Keyes!
Turn around!
Keyes, shut up!
Okay.
Now, alright, there we go.
Alright.
Okay.
No, not Keyes!
No!
Please.
Oh my god, I missed all the shadows.
Please, no, don't get Keyes!
No, not Keyes!
Oh my god!
What do I do?
Okay.
I wish I could be like, Ashley, stay here!
Keyes, stay here!
Why can't...
Why can't I be like...
Keyes, stay here!
Keyes!
Stay here, please!
Please!
Negative, Corazana, I've been engaged by Covenant Air Patrol!
Okay, Keyes!
Stay here!
Get in the locker, Keyes!
Get in the locker!
No, I just don't like the Assault Rifle!
The Energy Gun is so...
More accurate!
If you and the Chief can get us into one of those Covenant Dropships, I can fly us out of here!
I don't know, I'm not a fan of it!
Cause like, it's not...
I feel like the Energy Guns are much more accurate!
We'll just stay here!
We'll stay here, guys!
Wait, do they like come...
Infinitely come back?
Are they like...
Do they infinitely spot if I don't head forward?
I just wanna know!
Take that!
Okay, that's good!
That's good!
We'll stay here!
Sorry!
Hey!
We'll stay here!
Outta my way, mate!
Yeah!
Yeah, we showed them!
Alright!
Okay!
We're fine!
For now!
Guys!
I...
Stay here!
Do not leave!
Okay!
We can leave now!
Alright, everybody!
Slow and steady!
Slow and steady, everyone!
Slow and steady, men!
I don't trust any of you guys anymore!
Okay!
I'll try...
I'll try the assault rifle again!
He almost died there!
He felt like he wanted to play a little!
Oh my god, please!
I don't fight him!
Oh, thank god!
That's it!
Oh, we're safe!
We're safe!
Oh, thank you, John Halo!
Give me a minute to interface with the ship's controls.
Ah, no need.
I'll take this bird out myself.
Hunter!
What?
No!
Please!
Please be cutscene!
Oh, thank god!
Nice!
Time for a little payback!
You go, Keys!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
That was crazy!
You go, Captain!
He's dead!
Oh!
The Covenant believed that what they call the Silent Cartographer is somewhere under this island.
The Cartographer is a map room that will lead us to Halo's control center.
The island has multiple structures and installations.
One of them contains the map room.
The map room?
Oh, shit!
What's this?
Is it D-Day?
It's D-Day.
That's right!
Jesus, the pistol is so good.
Okay.
I'm gonna need up.
Okay, I knocked the needle.
Nice.
Wait, that's not...
Oh, yeah.
That's why I want it.
Give me that pistol!
Look, a Mark V.
What's that?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
He cheated!
Get out of here!
I got cheated!
He tried to fucking flick!
He was camping!
It's the beach episode!
Oh my god!
Just in time for my beach episode!
Tomorrow, guys!
Guys, we'll be there, right?
Holy fuck!
That was a firing squad!
Just in time for our beach episode!
You know it!
Open for reveal tomorrow at 5pm PSC, guys!
Just in time!
A beach mission!
No!
Oh!
Does anyone else wanna drive?
Let's go!
Oh!
Okay!
Okay, let's move out!
Okay, guys!
I guess I'll drive!
I believe in all of you!
Whoo!
You know what?
Does it really matter?
Are they coming over anyway?
It's just me and the team, right?
Okay, I'll just move forward.
Okay, we don't have to actually kill them, right?
I can just move forward?
Don't worry!
That's our spot!
Oh, I got him!
That's fucking Rhett!
That's Rhett!
I've hit a hundred headshots now!
I feel like I've hit more, to be fair.
There's no way I've only hit a hundred!
I feel like I've hit so many headshots!
Oh no!
I still hope you were able to enjoy the vibe though!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I see you!
I see you, ward ward!
I see you over here too!
Hey, you shot my ass!
Can I bring this?
I can!
Wait, I can!
Get over here!
I know where I parked!
What's the headshot Scott move?
Go!
Alright, here we go!
Alright, I can squeeze through this!
Okay, that's a bad idea!
That-
It might have been a bad idea to bring-
You killed him!
I didn't realize there were seven of them in there!
I didn't realize!
Okay!
I didn't know!
There were seven of them in there!
Alright!
There was always one!
There was a- Team wipe!
Let's- I wiped the squad!
Yeah!
Look at that!
I got team wipe!
It might have been my own team!
A wipe's a wipe!
I underestimated the Covenant's understanding of Halo's subsystems!
They've locked the doors!
And we don't have enough firepower to get through them!
Cortana to Keys!
Yes, we need help!
I thought you said you were sending some men to help me!
I don't know where- They didn't show up!
They have impeded our progress!
In this control center?
Wait, I'm gonna drive down!
Before the Covenant!
And failure people is not an option!
Yes!
Echo 419 to ground teams!
You need to find the security override to get this door open!
Let me in!
LET ME IN!
I don't know what to do!
What the fuck do I do?
Oh my god!
What do I do?
I have to find a security override?
Where?
I gotta backtrack now?
God dammit!
Now I have to take the car back?
I don't know how to take it forward!
I don't even know how to go in, not out!
Who does that?
The closet!
I can't!
Alright, I sound a back up!
Beep!
Here we go.
I did it.
I'm gyrating on there.
Alright.
Here I go.
Back up.
Alright.
Man, I can't believe they never sent me those men to help me.
Must have got lost or something.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Do I go around here?
Oh, man.
There we go.
Stupid.
That should be all of them.
Alright.
Can I die if I drive off this cliff?
Time to find out.
Oh, nice.
I lived.
Good.
Yay!
Nice.
Fast track.
Speed run.
Okay.
Maybe there's something over here.
No, we don't need them.
I don't go back.
I only go in.
Dead?
I can't tell.
Oh, yeah.
He's definitely dead.
Okay.
I don't want to use up all... Actually, no.
I should save ammo for that.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh my god.
I got like fucking...
Um...
What's the word?
I got fucking light mode there.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's so bad.
I actually got like light mode behind it from it.
Okay.
I don't have any shields.
Don't worry.
I can stay here and I'll be safe.
There you go.
Just do that.
Whoa!
I'm jiggle peeking.
Modern FPS.
Still the same.
Oh shit.
I can't jiggle peeking anymore.
I got it.
There you go.
I gotta be careful right now.
I'm like 1 HP.
Oh wait.
I don't.
Grenades.
Fuck.
I'm getting tired of this.
There we go.
I should kill him.
I'm getting tired of you all.
Get out of here.
Holy fuck.
That took so long to kill.
Yeah, I'm like 1 HP.
Wait, what?
You're still alive?
That's okay, right?
You were still alive.
That's fucking right.
It's headed for you.
Wait.
That's right.
You can't run away forever.
Okay, maybe you can.
There you go.
You better be dead now.
I know he's like here somewhere.
There's still like...
Wait, is he dead?
I knew it.
I knew you weren't dead.
I knew you weren't dead, you fucking whore!
Give me your gun.
Oh, there's a medkit.
Oh no, that's just a dead guy.
He was very medkit-like.
Uh...
I don't know if I can bring my car over there.
Can I put my car over there?
Alright, time to find out.
I don't know.
It doesn't seem very medkit-safe.
It's fine.
I did that on purpose, so it'll...
It'll be like positioned just right.
Uh...
Alright, let's squeeze through this tight hole.
Okay, I might die.
It's okay, it's my shield!
Where fuck did they come from?
What the fuck?
They weren't there before!
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I don't have to do that again.
Okay.
That's fine.
As long as I don't have to do that again, that's fine.
Okay.
Nice, you're all dead.
Come on.
Where's your gun?
Alright, I need your better gun.
Holy fuck!
How many are there?
Please!
You have a human medkit?
Human!
A medkit!
Okay, let me...
Get rid of this guy.
Oh my god.
At least I didn't get stuck.
Alright.
Get out of here!
You're just like little...
You're so annoying!
These little guys are so annoying!
They do nothing for the team!
Alright, now I'm up here.
Oh, on the beach?
Okay, but...
I'm already up here now.
Don't worry, I got this.
I like to live life on the edge.
Let's go find a medkit.
We here at Dookie, and friends do not offer cashbacks on Super Chats.
We are on us a button like honey.
Imposter!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, let's go find us a medkit, guys!
Let's...
I saw what I needed to see.
And I...
We need a medkit.
We need a medkit!
Alright, let's go!
There has to be a medkit here somewhere.
Oh, it's right here!
Holy fuck!
It was literally just right here!
Alright, thank god you guys died!
I told you guys, I like to live life on the edge!
There you go!
Okay, and I got...
There we go!
Alright, now I can do it!
Okay, I...
I heard the needler was good for this.
Okay.
There must be a needler here.
Nice, okay.
I knew there was like a hundred needlers.
Alright.
Wait, pistol is one shot?
Okay.
I just need to hit the orange, right?
What?
That?
You saw me?
Okay.
Okay, that...
That's not fair.
You know what?
Oh my god!
Okay, there's no way...
There's no way the AI saw me again.
The AI saw me.
Oh my god!
There was a medkit here!
That's fine.
They don't know.
Okay, that's pretty silly.
Let me just go around them.
That's really silly.
Just gotta give them one backshot.
I just turned you around.
No!
That's right!
Now you're paralyzed forever!
That's okay, right?
Stupid!
Get you a fucking backshot!
That's right!
Shot him in the spine!
She knows too much!
That is...
That is so sad.
Oh my god, I hate...
Area up.
Jesus!
Oh my god!
Fuck this.
Okay, I realized that was...
I got scared.
I thought that I accidentally did myself again.
That seems like something I do.
Okay.
Turkey's backshots will leave you paralyzed.
That's right!
You saw what I did to him?
Oh my god, this guy is so annoying.
I want...
Where's his other gun?
Okay, I don't want a needler.
I want...
There we go.
Alright.
Down I go.
Down, down I go.
Wait.
Oh wait, there you go.
What the fuck?
Oh, I was too busy meleeing!
That's right, I don't...
That's fucking right.
Wait, for my over health, do I like...
Can I like read?
What the fuck?
Okay, this is it.
That's it.
I'm tired.
Is my over health recharged right now?
That's fucking right.
Oh, it doesn't?
Aww.
It's okay.
There's like 20 more right here.
Wait, what?
Aww.
I can't take those?
Sucks.
Oh, this seems like a fight.
Yeah, this seems like a fight fight.
Oh wait, that's...
Whoops.
It's fine.
There's three more.
What?
That's a hit.
That was a hit.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll reset them.
They'll be like, oh, she's gone?
Joke's on you.
I'm still here.
Yeah.
What?
That's not fair!
Oh!
I don't need a beta melee.
Oh no.
Here we go.
What if I just go...
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait.
Oh my god, I'm off!
Here we go.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to bait the melee!
Guys, I don't think I know how to bait the melee.
Guys, I'll learn.
I learned, I swear to god.
I'll learn.
I'm trying to learn, guys.
I'm...
Guys.
I swear to god.
I'll understand it soon.
I'll swear to god.
Here we go.
I beat it out.
Two more.
Two...
I told you I'll figure it out.
First try, guys.
First try.
I did it.
I'm so good at video games.
Where do I go?
Here?
Oh yeah, here.
Hello, everybody.
There's some dead by daylight shit there.
Okay.
Wait.
I don't like that.
We just...
He has a golden armor.
Guys, it's quiet.
It's quiet.
I don't like it when it's quiet, guys.
Why is it quiet?
Oh no.
Uh oh.
Go back?
Guys, why does he have golden armor?
We're
on our way.
We're on our way.
Oh my god.
I see you.
I see you!
Where is he?
Oh my god.
This is fucked up.
This is fucked up because they're all invisible!
It's the fuck!
Oh my god.
It's not fair!
They're so fast!
What work?
I can one-shot them?
How?
Oh my god!
He's just shooting me!
With a pistol?
Oh, a pistol can one-shot them?
But he has shields!
Doesn't he?
I thought he had shields.
Cold War.
Nice.
Alright, I don't think I can walk down.
I don't think I can jump down there.
You're bringing us some heavy weapons.
After I saw we were up against hunters, I thought you- Oh, they don't have shields?
Oh!
Okay, I'll know now to one-shot them.
Now I know, guys.
Guys, I know that- I know there's fall damage.
I tested it out.
I- I know there's fall damage.
You can't fuck with me.
We already tested it out.
I didn't- I gotta do a double tap because I don't trust myself.
Stop that.
I know- And you know, like, when the shield disappears, that's when they're dead.
Alright.
Let's go.
There's a bazooka somewhere?
Too late.
I already made mine.
Alright, I'm already committed.
Let's go downstairs.
Orp orp.
That was just a bug, Doki.
Trust me.
You see, if it was any other chat, I would trust you.
But you are my chat.
Alright.
Do we go back or is it left side?
Wow.
You don't trust us?
You don't even trust me!
What?
You guys don't even trust me!
Oh my god, okay.
I'll just shoot his dicks, I guess.
I'm scared.
God, fuck this.
There we go.
There's a cat.
Look at that guy.
What the fuck are these guys doing?
They're like, we were just watching.
Nick.
Oh, he's dead.
Tori.
Alright, here we go.
I'm just gonna... No, I don't waste my shield on this guy.
Get out of here.
I know you're alive.
Get over here.
Doki, they were just chilling up on the cliff, Doki!
They're just hanging out!
It's a secret club!
No, no halos allowed!
Oh, it's my hill now.
My hill now.
I'm king of the hill now.
Oh, Bobby.
Oh no, my overshield.
Wait, what?
Here we go.
That's fucking right.
Alright, let's go.
What was that?
Guys!
Was that also a bug?
Fucking bugged my ass.
I literally...
Tripped...
Like...
10 centimeters.
It says...
Yes.
I tripped 10 centimeters, guys!
What was that?
Huh?
Oh, hey.
Rocket launcher.
How much bullet do I have?
Okay, five.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need it.
Oh, hey.
Oh, there's another warthog.
Aw, too bad.
Too bad my crew never showed up.
You still have overshield, so it's just a visual bug.
Oh, yeah.
That 10 centimeter jump I did was just a little bug.
Whoopsie doodle.
Where did my team go?
I guess it's like one more...
One more round.
Oh, there they are.
Okay, I need them to...
Come on.
Here we go.
Is that them?
It's fine.
I'll go higher.
Oh, hey.
Got your leg.
Like, what's shooting me?
Who's that?
You think my crew is okay?
You guys, you think they're okay?
It's been a while since I last saw them.
I need them to...
Come on.
Get a little closer.
I can...
I can poke you forever.
There's no falloff damage.
He's going up the hill?!
Okay, that guy is actually a pussy.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me...
Let me grab my warthog.
Give me...
Oh, now you're gonna come down!
Oh, and then you're gonna go back up the hill.
Alright, let me grab...
Alright, I swear to God.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I swear to God.
Every time I shoot, he goes back up the hill.
Alright.
Falloff damage is basically...
The further the bullet goes...
The less damage it does.
Alright, get over here.
I see you now.
Stop running up the hill!
Get over here.
Fucking idiot.
Was that worth it?
Was that worth it?!
Was it worth it?!
I'm not gonna use my rocket launcher on one eye!
I'm not!
Okay, see, I told you.
They're alive.
See, I told you guys.
There you go.
Okay, they were alive.
Okay, they were...
Oh...
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Are you serious?
No!
Let me shoot you in the back!
Come on!
Nice.
There we go.
I got it.
I figured it out.
Guys, look at that.
I'm halo-ing.
Look at that.
Backshot Doki.
Reign Supreme.
No one survives a Doki backshot.
Wait, my rocket launcher!
Wait, what are you- I thought- I threw- I thought what you guys were yelling at me about my rocket launcher.
I thought you were talking about- Alright, give me a sec.
Is that fucker's fault?
It's his fault.
Where did I leave it?
Oh my god, where did I leave-
Alright.
I think it was like all the way back there.
I'm pretty sure.
It was wherever the fuck I parked my car.
Wait, what?
It can de-spawn?!
I passed it.
Oh.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh my god, you guys actually fucking scared me there.
There we go.
Alright, we're bringing the car in too.
Thank god.
Guys, I- I almost believed you there.
I was this close to believing in you.
See, this is what I meant, guys!
What I said!
If it was any other chat, I would believe them.
If it- This is what I mean!
Alright.
You almost trusted us.
Close call!
Alright.
Now I'm playing Halo.
Low and steady, guys.
Low and steady.
Ooh!
Hey, guys.
Wait, can I put my Warthog through this?
Oh!
Is that how I would've, like, skipped half the mission?
I jammed my Warthog into that and the door couldn't close?
Is that it?
Oh, hey.
Hey, cutscene.
Go for the guy?
Okay.
Wait, there's health packs over there.
Wait, I hear something.
Wait, what the fuck?
That was on his head!
That was nearly on his head!
There we go.
I'm not rocket jumping that!
Oh, my God.
Okay, let me kill him.
I hate this guy.
I should kill him.
Wait, what?
He's not there?
When did he get over there?
Alright.
I fucking kill him.
Okay.
Oh, you gotta jump.
I fucking hate you.
Oh, you're right.
I just needed more overshield.
Oh, you're so right, guys.
You're so fucking right.
If only I had more overshield, guys.
If only...
If only, guys.
Oh, my God.
My lack of overshield surely fucked me over.
That was a real bug, Toki.
Wait.
Where did he go?
He's like, over there.
I don't know how fucked this.
What the fuck that?
Oh, this sucks, though.
Cause it's like...
I only have very limited rocket ammo.
I wanna...
I'd rather save it.
Wait.
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Come on.
Get over here.
That's fuck you, right?
Yeah, but like...
When will I...
I have like...
Seven...
Six ammo.
Read the...
Toki.
Just read the side of the rocket launcher while it's on the...
Yeah.
I wanna use it for like...
The strong...
Oh, my God.
Okay, sorry.
Not him.
He...
Not that...
That guy.
But like...
I meant like...
The guy with the gold...
The gold guy.
I...
That guy.
Look, he scared me, okay?
I got scared.
I'm gonna save this for the gold man.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
That's the overkill.
That's overkill.
What?
Where's he trying to walk to?
Where the fuck is the hunter?
Guys, I'm scared.
He doesn't know.
What can he do?
There you go.
Wait, what?
I...
Like, hit you.
My...
Turn around.
Come on.
I can just...
There we go.
Shot your back.
Alright, this guy will turn around, right?
Do you see me?
Hey.
WHOA!
Well there, buddy.
Nice try.
Nice try, buddy.
Nice one.
Nice.
What do I... Oh, wait.
Oh, wait here.
Oh, wait, this is where I...
Oh, this is the area I saw where I should have rocket jumped, right?
This guy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It really was one of the scariest games of the year when it was released.
I rated it to be as scary as FNAF.
Really?
Oh, this guy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
No, this is where you rocket jump, right here.
Oh, it's over here.
I have too much power now.
I know the strats.
I'm John Halo.
I'm gonna find that Halo and become the John Halo.
Oh, this feels like a fight.
This feels like a fight fight.
Oh, there they are.
We'll be in a tight spot if we don't get out of here before additional reinforcements arrive.
Let's find that map.
Um...
We don't like this.
Oh...
I don't like this.
Hello?
Where go?
Oh, there.
There's door.
Must be this door.
We go down.
Down is up.
You survived a headshot?
Okay, that...
Okay, no, that's a tart shot.
That wasn't a...
That wasn't not a headshot.
Oh, hey guys.
Sorry, I keep shooting you in the chest.
I couldn't help it.
Fuck, it's the big boys.
Where are they?
That's me.
I'm enemy.
I hear him.
Is that him?
No, okay.
I gotta...
I gotta be sure.
What the fuck?
Where did that guy go?
Where did that other guy go?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, wait.
He just walked backwards.
He just slowly walked backwards.
Cheater.
Okay, it's not my fault.
I'm fucking blinding this map.
I have to be sure.
There you go.
Get back my...
Rocky launcher.
Nice.
Yeah, Toki.
Now you have enough to do the rocket jump, Toki.
Do it right here.
Yeah, but this gun's better.
Isn't it?
This gun's always better.
I hear, like, some guy going...
Whoa!
What, what?
We're...
I'm a little lost.
Above me?
Where is that sound coming from?
I came from here!
Right?
Oh, there it is.
Down is up.
There we go.
There's a down.
Pick me!
I know you're there!
There we go.
Oh wait, he didn't hit the sh...
Aw.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Let me bail you!
My fucking...
My overshield.
Oh my god.
He dodged every melee.
That's crazy.
Holy fuck.
That guy was gaming.
He got some moves.
Located there.
That structure appears to be some sort of temple or shrine.
Like, let me backshot you!
A shrine is an unlikely place to put such a significant...
Alright.
Oh no.
Where did he go?
Keep trying.
Let me know when you reestablish contact, and then tell...
Where do we go now?
Affirmative.
Phone hammer.
Am I supposed to...
What do I do now?
Do I go back up?
Oh.
Okay.
Because I found the location, right?
I was like thinking about it.
I was like, oh I found the location.
Do I just leave?
Leave, right?
Oh hey!
The fuck?
Oh nice.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Huh.
I know.
Down is up.
Now up is down.
Okay, no.
Okay.
I thought it was...
I thought it was a natural threat.
Okay.
Give me a sec right here.
Wait, how do I get back up?
I said down is up, but like...
Wait, where's the stairs?
Where do the stairs go?
Ba-bum.
Ba-ba-dum.
Did I not come up from here?
What's it here?
Where the fuck did I come from?
Oh, the ramp!
Oh, I'm dumb.
It's like such hype music, but I was still stuck down here.
I was still stuck.
The music was for nothing.
I didn't know where I was.
Oh my god.
I thought I was gonna fall.
Oh no.
Come on.
God, you're so lucky.
You're so lucky!
I only have a pistol!
Fuck this guy.
That's right.
That's fucking right!
Okay, I need it.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
That's more like it.
Wait, I hear somebody next to me.
Where?
Who's shooting next to me?
Someone's shooting me next to me.
Five.
Fuck butter.
Oh my god!
You!
That's it.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
I didn't realize I needed to look up!
How many bullets do I have left?
Oh, not a lot.
Not much left.
Oh wait.
I knew you weren't dead.
I knew it!
I know when dead is dead.
Beat me!
Get your shield out of the way!
What, what?
It's just you!
Wait, what?
Who's that?
Okay, that's nothing.
I'm just paranoid.
Alright, I'm slowly heading over.
I'm slowly heading over!
That's right!
Oh my god, that's it!
That's it!
Get over here!
Still have my rocket launcher.
I'm ward warding now.
Where are they?
Woah!
Fuck this guy.
Oh, did he actually?
Oh no, he just walked backwards.
I was gonna say, oh my god, he actually fell down!
Fucking idiot.
I gotta make sure I don't fall down.
That I be the fucking idiot.
Okay, just in case...
Just in case something...
Oh no, okay, it's not him.
Okay, I thought...
It wasn't like...
I was worried that it was the golden armor guy.
Those are the ones I'm worried about.
Fuck this.
Worth it.
Get out of here.
Alright.
I got one med kit.
Guys, it will be worth it.
Me saving those...
Me saving...
This rocket launcher.
Where did my rocket launcher go?
Me saving this rocket launcher will be worth it.
I swear.
I swear to god.
I believe...
My three bullets...
He'll show up!
And then who will be laughing now?
I know he'll show up.
He's gonna go wart wart and then I'm gonna go boom.
I'll be like boom boom.
Alright.
Up I go.
I know you'll be there.
I know you'll exist!
I saw you in the cutscene!
Oh my god.
That was almost...
It was almost a hit.
I saw him in the cutscene.
I swear to god he's real.
I saw him in the cutscene chat.
Okay.
Oh, where's the other...
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm ready for him.
I'm ready for him!
I do it!
Okay.
Okay, but I do it!
I do it!
I knew you were real!
They all called me crazy!
But I knew you were real!
I knew it!
I knew you were real!
They all thought I was crazy!
But I was crazy now!
It's crazy!
Please!
Okay.
I knew he existed!
I got a little too excited!
That I shot myself too!
I didn't see him!
Yeah!
Cause I fucking nuked his ass!
I knew he existed!
I knew he was real!
He was real!
He called her crazy for telling the truth!
Oh my god!
This is my last one!
I knew it!
I knew keeping this was the right idea!
That's right!
I did it!
The last bullet too!
They called me crazy!
But I was right!
I did it!
I survived D-Day!
As a one man army!
They sent me in a solo mission!
Only me!
Whoa!
Alright!
I think this is a good part to end it guys!
Because apparently the next mission is one longest mission!
I would have been your daddy!
What a name for a mission!
Um...
But I'm gonna call it here everyone!
Uh...
But I hope you guys enjoyed the first part of Halo Combat Evolu...
Evolve!
I was gonna say Combat Evolution!
Um...
But...
I hope you guys enjoyed part one!
I've been having fun so far!
Um...
Not the...
The only thing I would say...
That I'm not having fun in...
Is...
Is the...
Is my Marine AI!
I...
Like...
Why does their AI...
Able to do all that shit!
And then my AI...
Just like...
Fucking bomb each other!
Like...
But...
Anyway guys...
I hope you guys had a great time...
Watching me play Halo...
For the first time!
Um...
Tomorrow is a very exciting day!
It is my first outfit reveal...
Since revealing the Bounty Hunter...
Skinsuit!
So I hope you guys come over...
And check it out!
Um...
We're having a beach episode!
Uh...
But thank you all for coming!
I'm gonna go...
Relax now!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go relax now!
I think I streamed like...
Around almost like...
Six hours today!
So...
Thank you all for coming everyone!
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated!
Posture check!
Get up and around!
To get that blood flowing!
And if you...
Stay up for me!
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Mmm...
Bye!